all right someone sent me this one it
had a juicy title it said after David
door and I'm done trying to empathize
with anyone my destination is to express
to you how I feel about all of what's
happening about the so called protests
which ain't no riots all right I'm just
gonna stop it there they're not nothing
but rights majority the protests are
just peaceful protests objectively
speaking that's just the truth
so they've only contributed to death
destruction chaos and just overall
Anarchy that's not true
policy makers have already put for some
bill for police reform they're already
proposing different things so the idea
that they brought nothing good is also
objectively false I'm gonna just say not
what my opinion is because he's entitled
to feel how he wants to feel about these
things and also good unless you think
police reform is bad then maybe you have
an argument there but to say that they
haven't accomplished anything that would
be an accurate first things first
I have zero empathy for any looters
anybody else engaging in violence none
of that I agree with you on that but
that's not let you like your thoughts
you're talking like it's everybody
that's at the right like most people
didn't engage in that I didn't have any
from the beginning I did not have any
before this thing happened while it's
happening or right now zero if you're a
looter shooter or whatnot looters or
shooters bridges the bridges collard
greens beans but number two there was a
little bit of empathy there for peaceful
protesters and when I say little bit I
do mean little bit I'm talking about out
of 100 percent maybe 2% a little bit of
this man really said 2% I'm not as you
when you have as much empathy for
protesters as you do for like your milk
cream I'm not about that cream after
what I've seen over the past few days
that 2% is is gone you have more black
people that have been shot killed during
these so-called protests then we're
actually cure
in incident we're talking about which is
George Floyd that was the original
purpose right because everybody's
protesting their carrying on because of
the death of George fluid no so that's
not exactly a cure people are protesting
policing in general and the way it's
done there they're not just mad about
George Floyd they're mad about the
system behind it would you understand so
to you to sit there and say they're
protesting just that or because that no
and they've made that pretty clear or
else they wouldn't be fighting for
police reform this is not just about
making sure that there's a new policy
that says no knees on people's necks and
this is not just about people dying at
the hands of police officers this is
also about bad das
this is also about you know disparities
in sentencing even when you account for
prior prior convictions right so it's if
you limit it to just when people get
killed then you're gonna have a problem
because I can pull up stories for you of
police departments that would frame
black men on purpose in order to keep
their conviction very high you know so
if you sit here and you say it's just
about how many people died therefore you
know because more people have died
during this protest it's not just no I
can make that same argument for 911 more
people died at war in Iraq and
Afghanistan than people died in line 911
does that mean that nine of the whole
war is invalidated that's not a good
comparison you can't look at it that way
okay that was the original purpose
because of one person that died who by
the way was not a model citizen at all
you're talking about a dope fiend that
guy that was on that's irrelevant his
priors his other issues while real and
wild reflected on his character does not
mean he deserves or doesn't deserve to
die just this is justice it should be
blind that's why I think what why she
has a fault does you have a blindfold on
right so when you sit there and you say
his character doesn't even deserve all
this
then essentially what you're saying is
that only people who are good people
deserve justice and I disagree with that
it's blind or it's not the main thing
that set me off and really affecting me
personally was death of 77 year old
David Doran he was a retired police
captain out there in st. Louis who
responded to a burglary call at a pawn
shop so he's out there trying to protect
the community trying to protect
businesses and what happens now unless
he gets shot and killed right outside
the
shot it also extreme don't Facebook live
okay let's just start off with this I
think any protester and most protesters
will deal with you that they want
justice for David door right so nobody's
sitting here don't prosecute the riders
nobody's sitting here don't prosecute
the looters who steal from people or
anybody who murders like no one's gonna
sit here and say this is okay and I
don't think anybody that I know of
really has been saying that and everyone
agrees get justice for him if the police
find the killer I doubt you're gonna see
how much people protesting being like yo
don't charge the killers if nobody would
say that there's gonna be nobody in that
process my granddad was 74 when he died
and I know how much he looked up to him
he was like my idol 77 years old shot
kill after 38 years and law enforcement
this man had five kids and ten grandkids
I don't care what he did in his life I
don't care if he was a ten-time criminal
I don't care if he was a saint I didn't
he didn't deserve to die we don't care
about what the life of George Floyd but
we're not gonna care about the life of
that man that died he died in a way that
was atrocious
and that's what Matt Lee sighs you
should have no bearing on whether or not
he deserves justice it has to be on your
head or how many grandkids yet if we
don't look at one we're not gonna look
it's in just people period so imagine
you know you go to your pop-pop house
for Thanksgiving Christmas or whatever
now that's gone all because the way you
went a flat-screen TV from a pawn shop
is that what you think that his life was
worth if that is how you expressed that
blacklivesmatter I can't really I don't
understand how that makes any sense no
one's doing that no no it's trying to
express that idea and no one think this
is right no one's born of Chicago and be
like all this gun violence is great
black lives matter no one's saying that
so I feel like this this is a poor
argument a man in Oakland
Patrick Underhill 53 years old he was a
protective services officer for the
federal government he would shock you
out there in Oakland trying to keep the
peace trying to make sure everybody was
getting safe just doing his job okay
where's the black life under protest for
Patrick I knew who David Dorn or anybody
else all right this is called the what
about ISM all right all you guys are
protesting this what about that
oh you you about that life matters what
about the black lives in Africa that are
suffering from also the disease and
famine huh what about them you don't
protect fighting gets one injustice
doesn't mean that you don't care about
others that's all I'm gonna say
you're really blinking things that are
not necessarily linked okay somebody
died because of a protest and therefore
it's black lives matter
I mean therefore it's exactly that yeah
it was a protest organized about that so
therefore he killed is black live matter
that killed them it's a sketch I hope
that you reach I hope you stretch before
you you did that reach because that that
is that is a that is a whole reach what
you're seeing right now on a national
stage the 77 year old man that got
killed the young girl that got shot
killed people that are getting beat up
assaulted people to getting guns pulled
on them black folks getting guns pulled
on them black folks getting the
businesses robbed didn't loot and burn
and everything else I don't think
anybody's gonna argue with you the inner
city crime it's not a problem we all
agree and and if someone shoots up a
school as a black dude right people want
him charged go to jail no one's and
normally you know what people who get
caught you know persuading violence
against someone else they go to jail the
problem is that police officers get away
with sometimes murder sometimes false
imprisonment
sometimes planting evidence like in a
previous video that we showed you how is
it that if I am caught with drugs
there's a huge problem but police
officers can plant drugs on me it'd be
on camera and they're still on the
police force what people are protesting
right now is a system of inequality
there's they're protesting the fact that
police officers and governmental
agencies have special privileges but are
not held to the same laws and standards
as everyone else and they use that to
oppress those who make the least amount
of money of us I get monster amongst us
so when you sit here and you say what is
this about why are you still doing this
black on black I feel like you're strong
Manning a lot of what they're doing
right now nobody says that violence in
Chicago is okay there are so many music
artists so many activists so many people
working on the sea
right now they're to try to fix those
issues but they run deep and it isn't
because they may be perceived as
ineffective that they're not trying and
that they don't care I'll try to finish
this cuz I don't want to not here is art
but his arguments right now so far have
not been good zero you see there on a
consistent basis in the black so-called
community between the black community
anyway it's black neighborhoods you see
if they're out of time in black
neighborhoods consistently okay so when
I talk about black on black balance is
talking about they I'm talking about
their everyday chaos pandemonium okay
just to be clear there's no such thing
as black on black crime like a
phenomenon where black folks
specifically targeted black folks on the
base no most people live around people
that have of the same race of them and
so if you look at crime statistics and
how they're reflected white people
commit majority of their crimes against
other white people black people commit
the most of their crimes against other
black people same thing with Asian folks
and Latinos and other minorities right
crime is a matter of proximity so when
you say these terms black on black you
you perpetuate this idea that black
people have some kind of innate hatred
for other black folks and that's why
they commit these crimes that's not true
in destruction that we do to each other
in our own communities if I'm talking
about that's why it matters so we might
want to call me yoke nor Uncle Tom or a
sellout or a or something like
that what do you even thinking about
here the curtain you for not want to
talk about the most important and
pressing thing you'll talk about some of
these criminals that get murder in the
street and sometimes rightfully so by
the police and some kind of injustice
but then when your granddaddy get killed
when your grandmama get killed when your
girlfriend your wife your sister your
mother your brother you want to keep
listening always good we're gonna think
it happen with this video is that this
man saw mr. Dorn die and he got hurt
understandably because it's a terrible
thing it's a terrible thing to have it
and he got hurt because of that when you
hurt and when things happen like that
people are gonna use a lot of different
excuses to justify their pain mm-hmm and
what happened well you know it's because
of this and that and I believe that's
what happening because there's
not a lot of reasoning in what he's
saying really but what I understand and
what he's saying is pain and I
understand that what happened to mr.
thorn is something that is atrocious and
that they didn't have to take place but
now you're putting all those things
together it's a part you know there's
different steps in grieving ingredients
you know I mean it was different steps
of that and that's one of the steps you
try to find someone and someone that
dead it's something that is uh the the
culprit for what you did oh I'm sorry
for what happened which which it's
understandable but it's not correct and
not right right a lot of people want us
to cover it and to be honest with you we
haven't covered anybody who died in the
protests we haven't covered protesters
who died we haven't covered rioters we
haven't covered police officer one of
them no but I want to do some so someone
DM to me and they said I think it's
important for guys to cover this I don't
think it's brought up meaning David Dorn
to invalidate the whole movement but as
a counter to the violent and writing
method specifically when such a large
group of enraged people and encouraged
is encouraged to be destructive in order
to garner attention innocent people get
hurt
seems like an inevitability that's what
they said I understand the rioting and
I'm not gonna sit here and deny that
it's effective of course it is but when
causes like David Doran happen as a
result it brings up the question about
what cost and I would agree with you I
don't think that most people that's why
you have so many protesters right now
who catch people and are kiss writers
and they try to stop them you can find
videos online and so many people trying
and they catch these provocateurs and
people who are trying to incite violence
okay
and we sit here and we agree with you
that is unacceptable but you cannot look
at the collateral damage of a movement
and determined that the movement is
therefore wrong
do you imagine if they said that during
the civil rights movement right because
you recognize that Martin Luther King
was labeled a terrorist right he was
labeled a wrongdoer a criminal people
wanted him in jail the FBI tried so many
times right and eventually he was
assassinated riots happened then the
civil rights bill was enacted you have
to also recognize that a lot of people
died during that a lot of people died
during those price and those protests
did that invalidate their coughs no
look at how many people died in Iraq in
Afghanistan does that invalidate their
cause we have to ask ourselves are we
using these arguments family are we or
are we being biased with this I could
keep going on and on every conflict
results in people unnecessarily died and
no one's happy with it no one's okay
with it no one but it doesn't invalidate
the movement because if we're saying
that this movement is invalid because a
small segment of it rights and loose and
it's unacceptable right we're saying
that then we have to invalidate every
conflict in the world and I don't think
that's an argument that people want to
stand on so that's pretty much all I got
anything else you wanna understand to
hurt I really understand the hurt I
think that but trying to find the person
that is guilty when all cause right is
really not the way to do it I agree
thank you all right that's it for
today's video thank you
[Music]
you